vs dice que es el comienzo de un nuevo
capítulo histórico en la banca Suiza se
completa La fusión de los dos mayores
bancos vs y Credit suicis y da lugar a
un gigante de las finanzas suizas los
próximos meses probablemente serán
agitados según Sergio dermoti presidente
del grupo vs sobre todo en materia de
empleo tenemos que reestructurarnos para
asegurar el futuro de todos los demás
empleados quién será parte del futuro
todavía es doloroso Pero obviamente lo
controlaremos nos sentimos responsables
y estamos plenamente motivados creo que
eventualmente Sacaremos algo positivo de
una situación menos que ideal se cree
que podrían perderse miles de puestos de
trabajo vs Credit swiss tiene 120.000
empleados en todo el mundo con sectores
de empleo anunciados supervisa activos
por valor de 5 billones de dólares el
acuerdo de adquisición es una mega
fusión respaldada por el Banco Central
suizo y con el apoyo del gobierno suizo
la fusión llega después de que Credit
switch se enfrentara al colapso hace
tres meses cuando el precio de sus
acciones cayó más de un 30% después de
la quiebra de tres prestamistas
regionales en Estados Unidos El
financial Times informa que vs está
fijando líneas rojas para el personal de
Credit suiz incluyendo la prohibición de
nuevos clientes de países de alto riesgo
y de productos financieros complejos
entre las preocupaciones que suscita la
fusión está la de si el banco Es
demasiado grande para Suiza una comisión
parlamentaria estudiará Por qué Credit
suites llegó al borde del colapso